Tom Hanks is here tonight my god
hard hard to think of a bigger star than
Tom Hanks which is why things got a
little awkward backstage just about 10
minutes ago
Coco hey Tom good to see you well great
to see you thank you so much for going
to do this the show it's an honor to be
your first guest back on your first show
so yeah about that you are no longer the
first guest this is awkward but you're
now the second the second guest yeah
I'm sorry we we got a we got a booking
that's so hot we just had to bump you to
the second it's not no Herschel is it no
we can't get him who is it it's it's the
Instagram egg the Instagram a the
Instagram egg with 50 million likes yeah
oh I got him beat him well excuse me
anyway I could just pop it and say hello
just a minute mr. Hanks Tom Hanks here
to see you yeah now it's not a good time
oh all right how about after the show
yeah not gonna happen yeah he might just
be shy I don't think he talks to anybody
I've got a reservation at 8:00
you